we like to think of numbers as being
absolutely true absolute truth incarnate
that numbers in some sense are our truth
handed down from a platonic realm above
us one plus one is always two it's never
going to change itself and become three
but every number comes from a
measurement of some sort and because we
humans are doing the measurements
they're not entirely true
a good example of this occurred in
Britain three women had two children who
died of SIDS and there was an expert
witness a very famous pediatrician in
sir Roy meadow who testified but the
probability of having two children died
of SIDS was infinitesimal one in 73
million so he argued with such a small
probability that is much more likely
that the women were murderers the
properly that of the child will die of
SIDS is actually not a straightforward
calculation it could be that there's
something genetic or there's something
even in the environment so if in fact
the first child dies of says the chances
of your second child dying SIDS are much
greater three women were convicted of
murdering their children based upon
testimony in the mid 1990s people
suddenly got very scared
that NutraSweet a sportivity sweetener
and diet coke was causing brain cancer
and what are the main lines of evidence
was that you had this rise in nutrasweet
and the rise of brain cancer strong
mid-1975 on so aha there must be some
connection well in fact there were a lot
of things that try to at the same time
if you look at the budget deficit and
how much more we were spending in
government than we were taking in in
taxes you saw that
brain cancers tracked extremely well
with the budget deficit in fact that the
correlation was almost perfect so just
because you see a rise in something and
associate with the rise in something
else
it doesn't mean of the two are related
in fact often it's not the case if
you've got a prosecutor who's looking at
fingerprint evidence and saying there's
only a one in a million chance of this
fingerprint didn't come from the person
I want to convict well if you're in a
city of eight million people that means
on average there's eight other people
running around the city who the
prosecutor could say exactly the same
thing about we do feel safe when there's
a number there it gives us something to
grab on to and believe is absolutely
true even if that number has no
foundation whatsoever
advertisers know this this is why four
out of five dentists prefer Trident it's
while Orioles extra impact mascara has
12 times more impact think about that
for a second how do you measure impact
anytime someone presents something in
quantitative or people will believe even
though numbers themselves may be perfect
because we are faulty in our hands
numbers can lie